je viens vers vous ce conflit vous le
couvrez aussi pour France 24 depuis son
commencement 2014 déjà avec l'annexion
du don-basse vous êtes ce soir à Kiev au
musée de la guerre un lieu chargé en
symbole que l'hiver
oui c'est le musée national de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale mais en réalité
ces dernières années c'est devenu aussi
le musée de la guerre qui est en cours
en Ukraine depuis 2014 en réalité avec
l'occupation des factos d'une partie des
régions de donuts qui est de loin par
des forces contre les par la Russie vous
voyez la carte ici il y a plusieurs
éléments dans le musée qui raconte
l'histoire de cette guerre qui dure en
réalité on Ukraine depuis 9 ans mais qui
évidemment est entré dans une nouvelle
étape beaucoup plus sanglant le 24
février dernier quand la Russie a envahi
ouvertement l'Ukraine sans se cacher
derrière ces soi-disant séparatiste dans
le don de base et j'ai l'honneur d'avoir
avec moi aujourd'hui une personne qui a
été je pense notre première invité à
l'antenne c'est terrible matinée du 24
février 2022 Étienne au garcova vous
êtes coordinatrice
internationale du crime crice Media
Center
de la guerre mais à la vue de cette
colonne de char qui est cette année
jusqu'à 60 km de char on a pris nos
enfants on est parti ces semaines à
l'ouest de l'Ukraine et on nous est de
retour que au début avril